it's alleged Slovenia - the European
title in 2017 as well there's JJ reddick
in the game coming off the bench which
is going to be a role for him this year
Redick from a jury in his fourth fourth
year with Dallas's steadily improved
first tunisian board player the NBA as
JJ Redick connects ona for so much more
confident coordinated out there than he
did when he came to the NBA is Redick
off the nice pump fake trains the jumper
to signed a couple of players who have
been injured including Wilson Chandler
video game Dennis Smith and Anton church
have been playing together boy play
opportunity coming off for JJ heretical
it's in the left hand I get through the
defense I'm either trying to close out
on Redick and now he attacks yeah that's
what that three-point shooting will do
for you pondering what to do here give
it a retic let him shoot a three he's
still perfect look at the feet by Koch
it's got a rejection by muscala Redick a
three
and he knocks it down JJ reddick stay
attached to him he is yet to miss a shot
Oh
[Applause]